l'association a été est pleinement
toujours mobilisés dans cette crise
sanitaire du coc vide 19 la croix rouge
française organise ses journées
nationales c'est du 12 au 18 septembre
un événement prévu à l'origine au mois
de juin est finalement reportée en cette
rentrée
particularité cette année le rendez-vous
coïncide avec la journée mondiale des
premiers secours
ce samedi vous trouverez partout dans
les yvelines des bénévoles qui
proposeront des formations aux premiers
secours adaptés à ce temps de pandémie
c'est aussi le moment de la quête
nationale pour aider l'association
écouter la présidente de la délégation
territoriale des yvelines de la croix
rouge nous avons impérativement besoin
de la générosité de toutes les personnes
qui nous font confiance
voilà et donc cette année pour tout dire
il y a trois moyens de pouvoir donner à
la croix rouge le premier vous allez
trouver partout dans les yvelines
des bénévoles qui vont venir avec les
trous comme d'habitude
le deuxième moyen et ça c'est nouveau
c'est vous pouvez donner un don par sms
donc vous vous composerez le 92 200 avec
dont 78 et vous pourrez donner 3 euros
donc ça c'est très important et la
troisième nouveauté c'est que nous avons
plateforme participative
il va nous permettre d'acheter 1000 kits
hygiène pour nos maraudeur la
croix-rouge et samu social dans les
yvelines et nos bénévoles tous les soirs
de l'année vont contacter des gens de la
rue et ça ça serait vraiment un énorme
service
alors le site internet de la croix rouge
des yvelines qui s'affiche à nouveau
pour toutes les informations vous pouvez
également retrouver l'association sur
les réseaux sociaux